welcome to this video has take off 8g
591 okay that was quick okay so I really
should check this opening a little bit i
really think i will the the fianchetto
the system is one of my big theoretical
regrets we're always thought okay this
is actually an opening that I should do
well in and it should be kind of up my
alley let's say but I never looked at it
really oh it's interesting you 6c going
45 base set up here he is Wow okay well
it should be quite nice for what by the
way I have entered the 2400 range again
you just if you play a little bit then
you're getting back to where you belong
in this in this rating ports um what is
this we're not just winning their pod
hmm
that looks good don't really see any
counterplay v5 i have d 5 so that's no
no worry at all i can also play a 4
maybe I should go away for why not it
grabs even more space and it's not quite
clear what blacks our plan is him
so what I'm line moves and something
that group to the one may be supporting
d 4 p-3 covering see form just doing a
little bit yeah tidying things up and
what really could do something is Knight
to f3 wow I understand that he's kind of
that he should do something but I don't
really understand this let's let's think
about it for just a moment what is the
big idea Bishop Bishop tease then looked
shakes and then he takes only three I
don't I don't get it I don't get it Rene
okay I'm taking um and then then let's
see
I simply fail to believe that so I'm
taking and then then then I'm then I'm
checking the details okay takes b7 I
guess right it's a whole piece this is
the this is the thing ok Ruger tool
laughs resign this is nothing and we can
take III but III but that's not not
doing anything damn that was it was just
a big disaster when you can probably try
to hang on like night over to f5 but I
think that this is this is a rather
normal line but I'm not really sure
about this is six and d5 build up after
e5 it seems that white is better if he
goes back I mean I'd he only has he aid
I can I was thinking of we are capturing
and then grabbing grabbing lots of space
here black is kind of stuck with that
dead bishop then this just gives the
pawn away 5 is not working at all but he
is almost losing him I have good moves
that support my position then night over
here maybe an h4 h5 as a way to get to
get to a real attack and blackheads
absolutely no come to play n is a paw
down so in opening disaster vm okay well
thanks for watching